ah
[Música]
y
l presidente yo vaivén se comprometió a
enviar al menos 20 millones de vacunas
de facer de modernas y de johnson y
johnson para finales de junio a los
países más necesitados bailén aseguró
que eeuu tiene que ayudarle al mundo a
frenar la propagación del virus para
asegurar así también la seguridad de los
estadounidenses las empresas las
farmacéuticas facer modernas y johnson y
johnson se comprometieron también en el
marco de la cumbre del g20 a donar 3 mil
500 millones de dosis entre este año y
el 2022 a los países más pobres y más
afectados por la pandemia países que
además podrán comprar estas vacunas a
precio de producción
concretamente cerca de 1300 millones de
estas vacunas se van a distribuir en el
2021 y el resto en el 2022 pzifer donará
2 mil millones de dosis modernas 995
millones de dosis y johnson johnson
hasta 500 millones de vacunas
[Música]
a final de año francia donará al menos
30 millones de dosis de la vacuna contra
kobe de 19 a los países más pobres que
le recibirán a través del mecanismo
kóvacs así lo anunció el presidente de
manuel marco durante la cumbre mundial
de salud de los países del g20 estas
dosis forman parte de las 100 millones
de dosis prometidas por la unión europea
al programa kóvacs por otra parte más
allá del gesto humanitario lo que
preocupa al ejecutivo francés es la
influencia creciente de países como
rusia y china en especial en áfrica
porque estos han sido los primeros
países en enviar a vacunas a esa región
por último de manuel macro se dijo
abierto a la posibilidad de levantar la
patente de la vacuna contra el alcohol y
de 19 pero solamente si esto va a llevar
a que haya una producción mucho más
acelerada de la vacuna a nivel mundial
por eso ha pedido un reporte a la
organización mundial del comercio y a la
organización mundial de la salud para
tomar una decisión definitiva
[Música]
la canciller alemana angela merkel
confirmó que alemania donará 30 millones
de dosis de la vacuna contra kobe 19 que
deberán ser entregados de manera
prioritaria a países en vías de
desarrollo en el marco de la cumbre
mundial de la salud
angela merkel también explicó que el
país aportará 100 millones de euros
adicionales a la plataforma kóvacs la
iniciativa global que apoya la
distribución de las vacunas esta
decisión de las autoridades alemanas
responde a la idea de que la pandemia
solamente puede ser combatida de manera
conjunta con base en el multilateralismo
aunque también se da en momentos en que
tras un comienzo muy difícil y plagado
de problemas la distribución de las
vacunas aquí en alemania ha mejorado
ostensiblemente y con ello se ha
reducido también la presión política
sobre las autoridades
[Música]